okay we're gonna go to five headlines
[Music]
today's five headlines brought to you by
the Benham brothers learn how to own a
business without it owning you get a 15%
discount on the Benham brothers new
course expert ownership at Benham
brothers dot-com / walsh Benham brothers
comm / walsh so fox has decided that it
will keep Nick Cannon onboard as host of
the masked singer terribly stupid show
by the way I I I kept hearing about the
show and I sat down to watch it for
about ten minutes and I almost couldn't
believe so people are why what is this
why are people watching it well I don't
know why I continue to be shocked by the
ramp its stupidity of our culture but so
he's still gonna host the show despite
the fact that he said white people are
soulless evil subhuman savages not even
in spite of that they're just pretending
it didn't happen like which is not
acknowledging it like everybody else
pretending it to happen so Cannon as a
consequence of making the most racist
comments we have heard on a platform
that size in a long time lost his
partnership with Viacom
which which actually he lost it
not even because of the white comments
but because the Jewish comments but
still keeps his hosting gig on Fox has
been offered other jobs to replace
Viacom and by the way we can be certain
he'll be back with Viacom in no time I
pretty much guarantee you that what this
means is that just taking another
example those kids who are remember
those kids at Jimmy John's who were on
on film playing around with with the the
the dough for the bread pretending it
was a news those dumb kids faced worse
consequences and a greater backlash than
Nick Cannon a major ubiquitous celebrity
who called an entire race of people
barbaric and subhuman this is canceled
culture if anyone's wondering what
cancer culture is this is it right here
cancel culture this is an aspect of
cancer culture that isn't acknowledged
enough cancel culture is a left-wing
phenomenon it is it is run by the left
it's what the left does well might as
well call it let we should just call
left wing cancel culture or left-wing
culture leftist or whatever you want to
call it it is a left-wing
phenomenon it's there there is there is
no canceled culture against the left if
there was Nick Cannon would be canceled
he's not even though he said the most
racist thing as I can you think of of an
example of a major celebrity or even a
not so major celebrity saying something
that racist recently that's the most
racist thing we've heard from someone at
that level in a very long time he's not
canceled the Jimmy John's people are why
because the left runs a cancer culture
it's all them so when when people on the
right or anybody else tries to hold a
Nick Cannon responsible hold them
accountable for being a a raging bigot
that's not canceled culture you can't
say oh I thought you were against
canceled culture I am
it's not cancer culture all I'm saying
is he just stood up and announced that
that his entire white audience which
which which I I'm guessing especially on
the mask singers most of his audience
are subhuman savages you should be
accountable but that's not canceled
culture canceled culture is when the
left goes after some random kids and
tries to destroy their lives for no
reason that's canceled culture okay
number two the squad's Ringo Ayana
Presley is back in the news here's what
she said at a House Committee on
Oversight and Reform meeting here's what
she had to say here here is her theory
on the history and formation of the
American police you know what's going to
be pretty good well listen to this many
black women and mothers surviving family
members have had to relive the trauma of
seeing their their loved ones murdered
and live streamed on national television
the mothers of the movement have been
trying to tell us for generations from
mrs. Hill to lose him and bath she
stopped murdering our children we must
listen you must Center these experiences
in this moment of truth telling and
reckoning and while June team is meant
to be a day of celebration and a freedom
and emancipation
again we must take stock of this moment
and be sober about the work that lies
ahead mr. Crenshaw is it fair to say
that the policing system in our nation
grew out of the practice of capturing
and often murdering individuals trying
to escape from his from slavery could
you speak to that just in our policing
system and how you see that influencing
modern-day policing no Ayana it would
not be fair to say it's not fair to say
because you just made that up on the
spot just invented that the police
department was formed based on
retrieving and killing slaves what every
civilization in history has had some
kind of law enforcement mechanism this
is not unique the fact that we have
police in this country actually it's not
unique the only countries that don't you
know the only time you're not going to
find any sort of law enforcement is in a
failed state or the worst third-world
hellholes you can find where they have
no sort of infrastructure or government
of any kind anywhere else if you have a
civilized society there's gonna be
police so you just but that's what
that's that's what we see now the left
they just make up just make up something
there's no reason for that just make it
up no justification off the top of her
head why not number three the media is
having conniption fits today because
unidentified quote-unquote secret police
are arresting quote-unquote protesters
and quote-unquote unmarked vans we are
told that this is the heralding of a new
age of fascism and tyranny it's a big
deal it's my god it's terrible we should
all panic the poor Prout the poor poor
protesters look what's happening to them
what have they ever done these
protesters besides commit serious
felonies every night for the last two
months straight I mean besides that what
are they done nothing here's the footage
that everyone is panicking about today
look
this what are you doing use your words
what are you doing use your words what
are you doing
use your words what is going on who are
you and LG will get you out what's your
name let's tell us your name okay you're
fine we'll get you out raw wood we got
you friend you just violated their
rights you just violated their rights
use your words
use your words okay so there they're
arresting and Anti Fog understand all
black with a helmet arresting that
person in front of a crowd on film
they're in uniform the uniform say
police on them what's the problem here I
I don't what are we worried about with
this this cuz they look scary is that
the problem and since everyone's you
know having a is very upset about the
unmarked vehicle since when what is this
a new console why is everyone freaking
out that they used an unmarked cops use
unmarked vehicles all the time
especially if they don't want you to
immediately know that they're the police
there's no law saying that they have to
announce down the street that they're
the police there may be times when the
police don't want you to know that the
police are right there so there's
nothing new about the fact that it's an
unmarked van cops use unmarked vehicles
all the time totally normal and also
necessary in some circumstances they've
got the thing says police what do you
want them to do what they supposed to
stop and ask permission excuse me sir do
you mind if we arrest you we were just
we I don't we were just stopping by
thought we'd arrest you you got time for
that now is it okay oh no okay we'll
stop back later but you don't you don't
you don't want us to arrest you at all
ever
okay well then forget about it never
mind you're good to go sorry we
apologize of course you know I'm being
sarcastic that is
actually what the left once that is how
they imagine policing and how it should
work if it works at all if we have
police at all that's how they should do
it number four that was in Portland this
also is importantly here's here's
another cop sharing his experience with
those lovely anti-racist white and Tifa
goons listen to this it says something
when you are at a black lives matter
protest you have more minorities on the
police side than you have in a violent
crowd and you have white people
screaming at black officers you have the
biggest nose I've ever seen I got to see
folks that really do want change like
the rest of us that have been impacted
by racism and then I got to see those
people get faded out by people that have
no idea what racism is all about never
experience racism they don't even know
that the tactics that they are using are
the same tactics that were used against
my people a lot of times someone of
color black Hispanic Asian come up to
the fence and directly want to talk to
me hey what do you think about George
Floyd what do you think about what
happened about this I go to the fence so
when white comes up if the police don't
talk to him every time I try to have a
conversation with someone that looks
like me
so when white comes up and blocks him
and tells him not to talk and then right
when I said that this white girl popped
right front of her she said he just said
that was gonna happen I straight up I
say you know I've been called the n-word
she's gonna call the n-word
why are you talking to me this way why
do you feel that she can't speak for
herself to me why is it that you feel
you need to speak for her when we're
having a conversation yeah I think I'll
just let his testimony speak for itself
there but I think that tells you
everything you need to know about antifa
if you didn't already know everything
you need to know about it five finally I
just need to read this report to you
this is from NBC Los Angeles which is
the local affiliate where all of this is
happening so okay listen to this
headline officials warn residents that
dangerous sex offender may be released
into Orange County and says Orange
County officials are warning residents
Tuesday that a dangerous sex offense
who has targeted young boys was due to
be released and we're asking for the
Governor of California to intervene
early Wednesday Costa mesta Costa Mesa
police tweeted that he had indeed been
released but was not currently in the
orange cap Orange County City leaving
many to wonder where he was Kerri J
Smith 59 years old was set to be
released from a state hospital where he
spent the last 20 years he was set to
return to acknowledge County where he
once lived as the hospital neglected to
renew a hold July 11th
2020 Orange County District Attorney
Todd Spitzer and the Board of
Supervisors made the plea Tuesday to
governor Gavin Newsom saying he's got to
do something they previously testified
that he fantasized about raping and
killing boys this according to the DA
statement spitzer said the sexual
predator has repeatedly testified under
oath that he will reoffended released
and we should believe him
in 2002 spitzer attempted to file 20
felony counts of a lewd and lascivious
act with a minor against Smith but the
statute of limitations had run out he
was sent originally in 1999 to a to the
state hospital after his then wife
revealed a letter that he had written to
a psychiatrist where he describes his
fantasies about raping a seven-year-old
boy he also says that he molested 200
boys and killed 3 this is what this is
what he testified during multiple
hearings he also reportedly likes to go
by the name mr. RTK which stands for
rape torture kill all right so you've
got a man who testifies to molesting
hundreds of boys promises that he will
reoffended n he is dangerous according
to even himself and he's being released
into the pot he has been released and
they don't know where he is and so far
the latest ID from the latest I've seen
anyway the governor of California has
not stepped in he's no he's not I guess
he's this is not on his top top of his
list of priorities I mean this is a guy
that is going to hurt and probably kill
a young boy at
according to him and there's no reason
not to believe him and he's out there
currently so if you live in Southern
California that's what he looks like
Kerri J Smith hey you yeah you
you right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now do it do it
right now
I thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated